[Music]  hmm I like that catchphrase oh yeah he's  got a bunch of them you have to watch  all of these episodes Terry I need to  learn everything about funbucket go  ahead pick a cards I will now turn these  cards into 56 different  extinct animals I believe this is your  card you're too lazy to even look at me  I'm limiting myself to three net  movements a day I only got one left oh  man why do I feel like this bodies are  not designed for this emotional overload  I've got a bucket list I haven't touched  a dolphin for good on the prices right  I'm supposed to fall in love on a train  in India and maybe the woman's a little  bit older than me  [Music]  we have been stranded here for a year  how is that not a problem for you  [Music]